[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey I thought some food looks really
good too oh good just joined it to focus
all right look don't my dad said to me
just before I got o me there because it
wasn't that obvious too busy obsessing
on my gamma-ray experiments I missed my
own father's death because I was
focusing on my destiny I didn't miss my
father's death because he was murdered
right in front of me by my sister whom I
didn't even know existed because she was
kept a secret from me my whole life
look terrible comparison just had
nothing to do with what you're going
through and my family it's like would
cost to fight amongst ourselves while
everyone else suffers for it no I was
gods and rooms and well this is sister
hello I don't even know if I found Peter
before you could kill your sister you
thought without each other you're not
the guy hammers here Dumbo doesn't sound
like a compliment it's totally a
compliment Dumbo Dumbo this sounds like
you're calling me Dumbo over and over
again
Dumbo home say once more I'll tell ya if
elephant think she can fly because
there's a magical feather and then he
loses his feather one day and he
realizes never anything to do with him
flying at all sorry
freakin feather man would I come from
was that me the whole time you see goats
his tail didn't even say anything we're
here yeah yeah get rid of it
[Music]